so your Dupont and you have a big
problem for decades you have been
secretly poisoning the world war toxic
forever chemicals that was used to
create Teflon and other non-stick and
waterproof products you told everyone
these chemicals were perfectly safe but
then the truth came out the area around
Houston Texas is back to normal tonight
after a leak at a chemical plant this
weekend left four workers dead another
hospitalized and released a cloud of gas
the state of California is taking on
some of the country's most powerful
chemical companies suing them for
producing toxic forever chemicals used
in everything from clothing to cookware
to Cosmetics research the chemical
industry often kept secret including on
pfos otherwise known as forever
chemicals people were getting sick
animals were dying and suddenly the
lawsuits and fines came flooding in
eventually governments from all over
ordered you to phase out this forever
chemical called pfoa for good people
were cheering the system really does
work DuPont's forever chemical was
getting banned finally people could
drink water and breathe air without
worrying about poisoning themselves in
the process but but here's the thing
they didn't ban All Forever chemicals no
all they did was ban One Forever
chemical pfoa so what did you do you did
a little rebranding you reformulated
your beloved pfoa into a new forever
chemical that's probably the exact same
toxic thing except with a slight twist
in this chemical composition so that
it's not illegal anymore and you called
it Gen X ah yes Gen X as if you couldn't
have chosen a more Sinister sounding
name for a chemical you then created a
brand new company to offload all the
production of this new chemical to the
Netherlands also that you can turn
around to the public and say hey we
listen to your criticism and now our
hands are clean if you've ever wondered
why you still see Teflon and Gnostic
products sold in stores this is why
this is how the Dupont family is still
getting away with poisoning the world
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
product band and billions of dollars in
lawsuits and fines piling up you as
Dupont went into survival mode if you
were gonna avoid total bankruptcy in the
end of your company you would have to
stop producing forever chemicals for
good the only problem was they were just
so profitable sure people weren't
getting diseases and all that but no one
could really expect you to just
discontinue your biggest Money Maker Now
can they so in 2015 you created kimors
kimors will be taking over your
performance chemicals unit performance
chemicals a very nice sounding name to
investors this new company will take
over your Gen X production and it would
Bear all the brunt of the pfoa lawsuits
so what your shiny new product and your
shiny new company Kimora set its sights
on Europe you took an existing DuPont
Plant in the Netherlands just right
outside the city of Rotterdam and change
the sun to say kimors however that was
not enough now you have to try your
damnedest to convince Europe that you
were nothing like duponts that camors is
here to make the world a better place so
you say really nice sounding stuff on
your website like how you're in Europe
to help create a better more than the
power of our chemistry now you're there
to produce hydrogen fuel to save the
environments while conveniently
forgetting to mention the facts that you
were also producing different versions
of the forever chemicals the world had
just banned and so the Dutch government
welcomed gamoras with open arms so while
the Dutch government made a big deal
about banning single-use Plastics and
how it plans to be carbon neutral by
2050 this plant started producing
massive amounts of Gen X and when anyone
asks about these new chemicals camors
just took a page out of DuPont's book
and promised that Gen X was completely
harmless and like sheep no one
questioned a thing within just a few
months Gen X chemicals replaced pfoa in
everything from Gnostic pans to plastic
and food packaging and within a few
years camors has spread all over Europe
and the forever chemical started seeping
into every single little crevice of the
continents
[Music]
just like pfoa Gen X never breaks down
once it gets into the air or water it
can spread over entire countries even if
they weren't producing the products
themselves and that's exactly what
happened in Europe today more than 10
000 forever chemicals including Gen X
have made their way all over the
European continents they are everywhere
this is our garden my father is
cultivating some stuff like tomatoes
pumpkins a lot of potatoes and this is
all polluted heavily polluted how does
it make me feel being a neighbor of 3M
Company I don't like them being my
neighbors but they are I use stuff of
gym which I don't want to but it's just
like that I have no other option they
are everywhere my entire family is
highly affected by that stupid chemical
forever chemicals have been found at 17
000 sites across Europe including the UK
almost 1 000 of these sets have
dangerously high levels of these
chemicals and scientists are even
recommending people who live near these
sites to avoid eating homegrown
vegetables and eggs laid by chickens in
their Gardens just in case and here's
where it gets worse when Dupont was
producing forever chemicals in America
Dupont had to get rid of their forever
chemical waste somehow so they just
dumped it into the ground and rivers the
same is true for comores in Europe
producing forever chemicals creates a
lot of toxic waste and they have to get
rid of this forever chemical way somehow
and luckily Kimora's have the perfect
solution
oh
you see even though Gen X isn't banned
in Europe any Gen X waste like the
actual chemical runoff and byproducts of
Gen X production is very strictly
regulated in most European countries but
not in the US no no no in America is
free to do practically whatever they
please with this Gen X waste and so
instead of processing this waste in a
safe expensive manner in Europe the Gen
X plant in the Netherlands simply ships
off this toxic sludge to a facility in
Fayetteville North Carolina and just
like duponts camors has not been very
careful about how disposals of his
forever chemicals instead that facility
in Fayetteville North Carolina ships off
this forever chemical waste one more
time to a place in Deer Park Texas where
they then proceed to inject it into the
ground in what's called a deep wall
injection plants deep wall injection was
also used by Dupont in the 50s to get
rid of forever chemical waste but it's
not very effective and almost always
leads to the contamination of the ground
and drinking water the state of North
Carolina is now suing two companies over
damage the chemical compound Gen X
caused to the state's natural resources
the complaint filed in Cumberland County
by attorney general Josh Stein said
Depon and kenmore's knew the use and
disposal of compounds like Gen X pose
significant threats to human health and
the environment the suit also asked the
court to void certain corporate
transactions Stein claims those
transactions are designed to Shield
billions of dollars in assets from the
state and others to the companies knew
were damaged by their product we're all
contaminated we made baby bottles with
it we made their formula like that's
what we did when I take a shower I am
showering in contaminated water that we
are bathing and cooking and cleaning and
contaminated water camors is planning to
expand production at its Fayetteville
Works chemical plant that straddles
Bladen and Cumberland counties public
meetings about the expansion start
tonight as legal battles continue over
the Decades of chemical pollution in
North Carolina from commercials and its
parent Dupont so Dupont Austin Gen X the
comoris camors makes it in Europe to
avoid American scrutiny while also
discreetly shipping the waste to be
dunked back in America and no one can do
anything to stop it a new study finds
that nearly half of the nation's
drinking water contains potentially
harmful forever chemicals
foreign
[Music]
in the early 70s Dupont wanted to
investigate the effects and
concentration of the forever chemicals
it was producing and what it discovered
was shocking at first 3M and Dupont were
checking to see the contamination levels
of their workers and so naturally they
needed a control they needed to compare
those workers blood levels of CA with
the population so they could see what
the difference was so they started going
to archived blood supplies and checking
to see what clean blood versus the blood
of their workers might look like there
was no clean blood they tested kids they
tested adults they went to Asia they
went all over the world and everywhere
they looked practically they found their
chemicals in people's blood and this is
exactly what will continue to happen
with Gen X these chemicals don't respect
political boundaries they are found in
every one of you it doesn't matter if
you've only ever drank from the cleanest
possible water out of glass bottles it
doesn't matter if you you never lived in
the city away from the pollution or if
you've only ever eaten organic food
forever chemicals Gen X and
microplastics have made their way into
the bodies of almost every single person
on Earth including you whether it's
through the air you breathe the water
you drink the food you eat or even the
toilet paper you use that's right not
one toilet paper brand tested around the
world came back free from Forever
chemicals and these forever chemicals
are wrecking havoc on your hormones and
health
[Music]
Gen X exposure can cause a long list of
serious health problems including damage
to your kidneys liver immune system and
reproductive organs it can even cause
cancer but that is not where the list
ends forever chemicals also disrupt your
hormonal balance it's been shown to
cause infertility in males by literally
blocking the function of testosterone
and lowering your sperm counts and in
women it's the same story forever
chemicals have been linked to female
infertility and female hormonal
imbalances as well as Dr Shanna Swan
puts it the average 20-something woman
today is less fertile than her
grandmother was at 35. in other words
these forever chemicals are literally
making men not men and women not women
it's the reason why testosterone levels
have dropped by 59 in the last 40 years
alone in hot take it's probably part of
the reason why you see so much gender
fluidity today video on this coming soon
and the worst thing is that just like
pfoa Dupont and comores will bear the
evidence of the dangers of Gen X for
decades to come and it won't get banned
until a bunch of people start developing
diseases right now there are no medical
procedures that can completely clear
your body of forever chemicals like Gen
X in fact the only way to lower the
amount of forever chemicals in your
blood would be to donate blood every 12
weeks or to donate plasma every six
weeks and even then you will only be
able to reduce your pfas levels by 10 to
30 a year but that doesn't mean we can't
at least fight back against these
effects though and this is what inspired
the creation of amplifier a company
based in the Netherlands who is front
and center of this forever Chemical
Crisis and what amplifier found is that
pine pollen is one of the most effective
natural remedies you can use to fight
back against the effects of these
chemicals this stuff pollen has actually
been using medicines for at least 2 000
years and pine pollen specifically
contains all four major male sex
hormones including testosterone and when
you consume pine pollen it's been found
in studies to increase testosterone
levels almost immediately it can also
help you improve your overall hormonal
imbalance while also regulating your
immune system so your body can fight
against disease an amplifiers pine
pollen is cultivated in the Himalayan
Mountains as far away from pollution as
possible it's 100 natural and it's got a
two year shelf life once you open the
packaging if you want to pick some up
amplifier is giving the viewers of this
channel a special deal that you can only
get by clicking the card on the screen
or by scrolling down and clicking the
link below so click the card on the
screen or click the link below to get
some now thanks to amplifier for
sponsoring this video and making this
sort of content possible stay dangerous
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign